you
there is a fantastic community spirit
both in in timnath and children mystique
tin heritage here shall we say so fine
is place in the world in which to live
we've got to an example of every sport
sporting event that takes place in
timber then that moves over to the rugby
club and of course the torch is expected
over the bridge around five-thirty it's
going to be an absolute stunning time it
is so special that we have a talk coming
through tinder and I'm so very very
proud but quite right it's a great time
we are a lot of energy and it is really
a town before the community with such
life
what so special about Timbers well it's
coming across the bridge here so
thousands of people can see it seven
thousand people could come and see the
torch running across the bridge it's in
the most beautiful sight and most
beautiful seaside resort well today I'm
just doing some break dancing their most
is to show people what it's about and
doing some free mini workshops to
teachers and basic moves nothing too
crazy too soon as a foundation for the
work here and dance doesn't just don't
have a bit of fun well the Chordettes
have been around since the last 32 years
and we started in timber I think it's a
wonderful opportunity for people around
the country to recognize Tim May and is
surrounded districts to come here on
holiday to push the profile of the town
can only do it good don't need to tell
you about it look at it I mean there's
people come out from all over to it to
be part of this to bring youngsters out
if even the dogs are acting I just hope
that something like this she's going to
continue year after year because it
should be an annual event where by the
Queen's come together and share
celebrating she come to timber because
the seaside is beautiful and the scene
the malls are close by is so much to see
in do it
beautiful place to come to
Timoth is absolutely going to be put on
a map and this is going to be something
with highlights water can offer as a
tourism destination so I think what we
will see is people saying that's an
interesting place we want to go there
the olympic committee had a very
definite plan about where things needed
to be and it is very much for district
councils who towns and parishes to fit
in around us but you still got to bring
it to light
and rolled up there 20 yards away and
start been a long time coming in this is
a nice going where there's a British up
collapse yeah
I felt amazing you know is mazing for us
it mean so much to us because as you
notice whether from we went to the
timber schools and there we all met in
that school and that's what a band slide
and so yeah we know this place by the
back my hand being on that enrich of all
our families there holding the torch it
was just an amazing food ya know we'd
love to we would like to play down here
as much as we can I bet you ten years a
day will be back on to the demo today
has been a fantastic demonstration that
it really means something to people have
24 primary schools here and they had a
competition so you know really drilling
down the sporting message from the
Olympics into those local areas is
fantastic it's just great to get young
kids involved in sport at a young age
because hopefully that will mean that
there's a lifelong habit we have news
here today they are the biggest rock
band on the planet I've invited matt
bellamy and the band to come in and run
the council for the day so hopefully
that will mean there's a lasting legacy
really because we do need to involve
younger people in local politics Tim up
is a great tourism destination so much
service is absolutely the place to come
to when it actually hits the ground and
people start to arrive and that
atmosphere starts to build you feel that
community spirit really coming together
what we want is people to come back you
know and come in a close season and the
longer season because it's a great place
to be watch the video that we put
together and tell me that you don't want
to be here because I believe that you do
it's a great post
you